hello believe nation today we're going
to learn seven ways to find your passion
so one of the most common questions I
get asked my audience is how do I find
my passion we also received as that
question from Joe McVicker son who's
from Armenia and is one of our YouTube
viewers and so we thought we're gonna
share our seven ways on how to find your
passion
[Music]
number one is immediately explore and
the idea here is whenever you come up
with an idea that you think you might be
interested in instead of letting it sit
and sit and sit and weeks go by and
Munsell gly and you've done nothing
about it just go out and find some small
way to get started on it to see if it
makes you come alive until you want to
do it again and again number two think
about what makes you happy when you wake
up in the morning try to observe what
makes you happy
what's the best thing that you're
looking for that day is it the cooking
is it hanging out with your friends or
your family do you want to go out with
dancing or your actual job makes you
happy you want to go and get things done
you're excited to change you're making
in somebody's life and or in the
corporation as well right so just think
about what are the maybe a few things
that you're excited for is it working
with the people doing something for
others just hanging up with your friends
enjoying the music I think once you look
into those clues you would have more
ideas on what is it that you want to do
in life number three is say yes more if
you don't know what your passion is and
one of the easiest ways to explore and
find new things is say yes if your
friends invite you out to do something
that you've never done before normally
you might say no that's not me that's
too scary I've never done that before
get into the habit of saying yes more so
that maybe going snowboarding maybe
going salsa dancing it maybe joining a
book club you never know what it's gonna
be
say yes to experience it and then see if
that thing makes you come alive or not
[Music]
number four model your heroes so for
example me I'm really passionate about
Michelle Obama and I follow her every
day i watch her videos and i follow what
she's doing in life the reason I I do
that is because I realized I'm really
passionate about all the causes that
Michelle Obama is passionate about she
really likes to help kids she really
cares about kids development the future
opportunities for them and giving
everything you can give to the kids
because they're our future
and I find that same thing for me by
following her I also realized how
passionate I am about kids not only
about having my own kids but anytime I'm
in the environment of kids it just makes
me happy I look at them and I see so
much potential in them so I believe if
you follow your models you can also find
your own passions here the alex resent
is passionate about having her own kids
just so you know number 5 is remove the
pressure to have it work so many times
when you're starting something new it's
a first time going out trying something
you put so much pressure that this has
to be the thing that you're gonna fall
in love with or a lot of times you need
a little bit more time just like if you
are going out on a date with somebody if
that has to be the one and you put so
much pressure on yourself that that has
to be the one then it's probably not
gonna work out well you want to allow
for time for things that happen and so
as an example in the salsa dancing
business when I first started salsa
dance and it was a fun thing to do I
never put so much pressure that this had
to be my business and on paper I was
really tall so I took big steps which
isn't good I didn't you know learn the
music growing up I don't speak Spanish
all of these things were against me that
if I went into that first event thinking
like this has to be my next thing I
probably would have left and never come
back to it because I put too much
pressure on myself and so don't put that
much pressure on yourself that that has
to be the thing that works out your
first time through give us some time we
play with it and see we're
[Music]
number six trouble more troubling
similar to what Evan mentioned earlier
saying more yes to your friends or
family will help you explore more ideas
and when I say trouble you don't have to
go all the way to Africa or to India or
to Belgium or anywhere else to find out
your passions you can go to the next
community you can go to the next city
and see what people are doing there what
is it that makes them happy what like
what other activities are they doing it
could be skiing it could be snowboarding
it could be going out dancing similar to
Evan and I if you travel more and be
open to more ideas of experiencing new
things it will also help you we're
finding your passions number seven is
try anything once I like to document
allottee I'll try anything once
even if I maybe have tried something
similar and it didn't have results I'll
still go out and try anything once as an
example take that approach to I tried
ski snowboarding I tried rock climbing
and I tried salsa dancing all in the
same year almost and the rock climbing I
tried once and I hated it and the thing
was in my crotch and it was
uncomfortable and right like some people
love it like Rosanna
me I went once is like okay that's I
said yes I tried it once I'm done
snowboarding I picked it up I loved it
I became obsessed with it for you know a
season and a half and now I go once a
season twice a season although I haven't
done this season so maybe it's gone and
salsa dance that I tried once and I
liked it and I came back and you know
ten years later still dancing still
having fun owning the business and so
just adopting the mentality of trying
something once whether it's going out
with a friend or something whether it's
seen an ad for something that you want
to you know potentially try whether it's
somebody offering
new food that you're gonna test out when
you get an opportunity that you haven't
done before just get into the habit
saying I'm gonna try out once give it a
shot so that's our take on the seven
ways to find your passion and we'd like
to know which one you like the most and
if you'd like to add eight nine or more
you can also add it in the comments
leave your thoughts down in the comments
below thank you guys so much for
watching we believe in you and hope we
continue to believe in yourself I know
whatever your one word is much love guys
we'll see you soon